das eisen verspeist wird das gehört sich
so diese alle sachen die sich reimen bay
kann man essen ja ok man kann auch
einluden
101 s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge microsoft heute
spielen wir nichts geringeres als team
jump league und wir haben jemanden dabei
den ist schon lange lange lange nicht
mehr auf meinen channel zu sehen gab
aber ich freue mich dass er dabei ist
und die spannung steigt
die wsg jenny hart er sagte danke schön
dass ich mal wieder dabei sein
sie haben lange lange versucht etwas auf
die beine zu stellen aber irgendwie dann
kann ich nicht dann kannst du nicht und
keine ahnung wir waren das ist war ein
bisschen inkompetente sind um angestellt
aber dass du das sowieso das kann aber
auch generell sehr gut aber jetzt ohne
witz wir haben alter weißt du noch
wann wann fing das wann fing alles an
es gab irgendein anlass dafür genau
dingsda damals noch diversity war das
diversity ist da unserem app oder die
hat mir damals mal aufgenommen sogar
genau der welt ihre kinder besser diesen
ist nicht cool weil die hier willst du
dumm war für die rätsel dann wie gesagt
okay lass mal pvp ab aufnehmen und das
war vor drei monaten jetzt kommt die
piraten war ja das muss irgendwie keine
ahnung und dann habe ich halt
geschrieben dann hast du nicht
geantwortet haben dann hast du gesehen
hab ich nicht geantwortet und dann
kannst du nachts und ich immer nur
tagsüber und das ist irgendwie so keine
ahnung
es ist passt einfach momentan nichts
sagen du bist ein tag eule oder wegend
lich nicht aber momentan irgendwie habe
ich wenig zeit nacht so keine ahnung
du bist immer weniger gewesen damit ist
so früh ins bett musste wo ich nachts
konnte ich musste ich will nie früh ins
bett gegangen
ja aber es meistens um was gezockt und
was in der du meinst ich weiß es nicht
es geht früh schlafen
kann mich nicht mehr daran dass zwei
aber ich bin richtig schlecht ich kann
das spiel gar nicht mehr irgendwie
zappeln habe ich voll verlernt irgendwie
noch für derzeit 90 ballack aber kurz
den flugmodus rein ja leute ich wollte
doch was zum thema tüv erzählen deswegen
macht es einfach mal der aufnahme
erfahrt ihr auch was zum thema tüv und
zwar ihr auto kompetenten könnte ja mein
ratschlag geben und zwar sind marissa
kleine sommerreifen die ich mir heute
habt drauf machen lassen tatsächlich am
mitte juli hat er sich eine winterreise
ritter sie fast neun jahre alt obst hab
ich alter ich komme da nicht drauf ich
bin so schlecht sind neun jahre alt
haben aber noch genug profil und die
frage ist jetzt obwohl sie neun jahre
als sind was soll man machen
also ich habe in diversen internet foren
gelesen dass man sofort stirbt mit neuen
reifen fährt
andere meinen wiederum jahr scheiß drauf
kannst du machen
ich bin mir unsicher hat jemand von euch
der flächen plan und kann mir das in die
kommentare schreiben
oder vielleicht könnt ihr auch wenn euer
vater mutter oder großonkel oder aber
ihr haus meerschweinchen besonders
kompetent sind dem thema auto könnt ihr
mal fragen und das feld in die
kommentare
eine große hilfe ja genau das war das
thema tüv aber jetzt schon spaß keine
ahnung wenn du jetzt keine ahnung wenn
jetzt einen neun jahre alten
videorekorder oder kanada mit tanz
bürger irgendwo hast dann kannst du auch
noch essen wenn er gut neun jahre alten
videorekorder würde ich nicht essen
liegt aber auch daran dass ich auch
allen neuen video recorder nicht essen
würde immer im allgemeinen hat sich das
bei mir irgendwie nicht so durchgesetzt
sowie die revision weise hier nicht aber
ist doch so schön damit immer so
kabelsalat oder nicht bei der s-bahn
daher kabel saarland stimmt und eine
ausnahme wäre es auch wenn nicht so
schlecht wenn die videorekorder aus
eisen sind dann kann man sich verspeisen
ja das ist nämlich einheitliche auch
eisen kann man verspeist genau das ist
eine alte mode und tradition dass und er
ist jetzt auch wenn ich jetzt auch
machen das reisen verspeist wird das
gehört sich so diese alle sachen die
sich reimen bei globell kann man essen
ja okay also wie die sich reimen wie
meinst du dass er keine ahnung ich habe
auch kein beispiel aber eine de domain
ist wenn sich ein einen wert für essen
mit dem gegenstand drei auch genau ein
werk für essen mitten im gegenspieler
dann kann man es erstens so sachen wie
verspeisen oder genießen
ok man kann also einen besen fräsen
das ist vollkommen richtig man kann auch
einluden einluden einen zuhälter
ich beschäftige mich immer film im film
ihr zuhälter in meinem alltag
oder man könnte ich auch nähe man kann
ich nehme man kann keinen juden wurden
da waren die hügel
darauf hat sich die aber war also leute
nicht richtig guten junge diese sprung
ja ich bin erstmal länder bezahlen also
ich sag dir ich bin halt wenn man kurz
vor knapp fällt ich bin am letzten
sprung jetzt in velen natürlich
zusätzlich vollkommen raus bei mir auch
so unfassbar scheiße und ich hänge jetzt
die ganze zeit hier am anfang habe ich
durch geschafft und den letzten sprung
ungelogen den letzten nicht easy ist
verpackt direkt kopfschuss aber das
alter mache ich es mir auch gerade wir
dürfen nicht damit aufhören was sehr
gerne die kommentare auch mal ein paar
coole reimer aus dem thema essen und zu
denen auch mal die kommentare wenn ich
was einfällt was kann man noch mal
machen vielleicht man kann einen jahre
man irgendwas kann was kann man denn was
ist ein gegenstand mit ampeln oder so
klampfen gleich klaren aber müssen
doch man kann klampfen mampfen ja und
ich konnte man kann auch ein
man kann auch mal was gibt es noch
hey ich versucht habe mit sich gönnen
irgendeinem aber es geht nicht also dass
noch was noch was noch das match
da wir unsere skepsis siegen ohne witzig
findet direkt aus als ich aber hier
gerade geht gar nichts bei mir schreibt
mir einfach an karten skript das ganze
kommt extra aus führt soweit wir ins
match kommen
das macht einfach time retail blieb und
wenn die auf null ist dann extra
ausführen was kann was kann man noch
machen essen ude nicht ob ich da
manchmal die leute dran
genau deswegen kriegt mich das auf weiß
dann einfach nicht mehr weitergeht sorry
leute ja das ist ein problem
gameplaytechnisch kann ich aber den
sprung schaffen dankeschön monopolist
alterung und jetzt noch an die scheiß
dankeschön gedroht da warum shop
deswegen will ich beim ersten versuch
schaffen
dann gib mir gib mir weiter für essen
wenn du gerade die nach der mega
unkreativ kapazitäten hier haben wir
schon ein uhr nachts heimische vorbei
ich bin ich auch gerade irgendwas coole
leute man dass ich denke ich denke die
werden genug sachen in den kommentaren
haben auf jeden fall davon überzeugt auf
jeden fall also in den blumen die man
tun kann das haben wir schon gesagt man
kann noch fressen boden
damit können hat mir irgendwas müssen
was machen ja so was ist immer voll
diskriminierend alter mir mehr witze
einfallen zum beispiel dass man schiiten
eaton kann aber sollte ich will gefolgt
von voll voll diskriminieren aber was
ich suche gerade
ich schätze ich nur der angewandten
reflex dass man an einem reflex halte
ich könnte jetzt dazu ein richtig
richtig krasse reallife story erzählen
okay ich bin aber voll darum gegangen
ich weiß jetzt erzählen sind das volk
von privat eigentlich okay ist natürlich
ist man ich weiß nicht das ist so sein
kindheits moment für mich wie eigentlich
dass du kannst ja riesig ich kann nicht
hütten
ich bin dauernd tüte worte [ __ ] kochbeck
irgendwie der herr wen ist
kreditanträgen bisschen seltsam den
krippen unterstrich der hat auch schon
so nahmen als wollte irgendwie gerade
das fenster geben nicht jahres hat
glaube ich auch kein nach back bekommen
aber ich kann mich auch irgendwann ich
da irgendwie auch in der ecke war
wir könnten natürlich jetzt scale punkt
ex aktivieren okay okay das bekommt muss
man sacken jetzt hier im schläger wird
jetzt mal wie viele wie viele auffrisst
und werden von einem von einem penis
wahrscheinlich wahrte gegen rangers
erstmal die angel ahlmann
ich habe jetzt so lange ohne eingespielt
nein ich dachte du bist hier wird hier
bin ich da nicht mehr viel eben gerade
nicht ich bin relativ da alles cool aber
der teppich über deinen skin kann es
sein dass es geht und wenn ihr
dankeschön ich musst du dich ohne ist es
okay ist man hier finden eines doch gar
nicht braucht das ist der das ist der
klub dann das ist er heiß aber sagen
nein diskreter
aber werner mang ich bin dauernd ich hab
ein herz wir müssen ja er hat mich hat
nicht mal angeschaut
gg wie kann man das machen hex hex hex
ich kann den versuchen den etwas ich
komm rüber zudem müssen mehr machen dass
rabatte genau an den weg an die weg ich
komponenten
sehr schön was irgendwie alle gehen
jetzt so richtig sechs heute jetzt mal
nicht aber hacks und jetzt kann ich
würde sowas von sterben hab ich dich ab
einer marke sehr schön aber er lebt
wieder also liegt immer noch unser
letzter gegner jungle pvp aber egal
jetzt kann ich auch als regel und zwar
alles nach was ich obwohl er durch die
einen schmutzigen schuhe um oder hier
und das dritte dann sogleich hörst du
denn ich habe jetzt weniger material zum
abschluss können fans auch immer sein
essen ja ja ok eisen verspeisen kann ich
guck dir so nach pilzsuppe kekse ich
nicht fleisch ich könnte wer wäre ich
auf euch in der ersten folge gegangen
vielleicht bin ich das ja und vielleicht
ein aus eurem team getötet dann könnte
ich bremen verschlammen kann man sagt
man nicht so schlimm sagt er ich könnte
bremen schlemmen oder ich könnte auch
wenn ich eine vorliebe für louis vuitton
habe könnte ich taschen vernaschen und
damit jetzt 321 co genommen egal wie du
läufst das niveau ist das nämlich will
kurze trip ist ja was soll ich muss auch
mal ganz kurz essen
ok dann lasst uns loslegen drei zwei
eins meins
ich kenne sie diverse einer papier also
das auto kicker problems gerade heraus
ja kommt nicht mal nicht mein ding jetzt
geht eine los sagen hat herr zurück
tristan ist doch keine angst keine kein
bogen war gemeint war gemein form ja
schon ein bisschen überrascht scheiße
also wie kann ich mich wieder rechnen
wie kann ich das vor der folge vor den
göttern vergeltung bitten
ich ziehe einfach in den himmel und sehe
dass da entsteht wenn da oben erzählt
okay gut drei leute das was heute check
mal den link in der beschreibung ab
dafür zusammen guter junge
wir sehen uns in der nächsten folge
wieder haut rein macht's gut und